it was a Tuesday after an ugly win and I  was flying higher than coach Ferster  before a Noel meeting that's when he  walked in fresh off his first wind he  was six foot five with a bow tie and a  face that was downright punchable I want  to report missing persons who's missing  the Los Angeles football fans damn where  world was LA Chargers fans kidnapped  dead watching preseason Lonzo ball I  wasn't sure but I knew who I wanted to  talk to someone who actually had fans  that dinky stadium mr. Wentz where'd you  get all those fans in LA I don't know  North Dakota check the wagon sue it's  clean just some Bibles and the other  Kelsie let's bring him in for question  what looks like he eluded the sack  kid reminds me of a young me if I ever  had passion for the game where to now  it's LA there's got to be football fans  somewhere I think I've got our next move  I give up